let's say i have some function f of x
that is defined as being equal to x
squared minus 6 x
plus
for
all x and what i want to do is show that
for this function we can definitely find
a c in an interval where the derivative
at the point c is equal to the average
rate of change over that interval so
let's let's give ourselves an interval
right over here let's say we care about
the interval
between two and five and this function
is clearly both it's can definitely
continuous over this closed interval and
it's also it's also differentiable over
and just has to be differentiable over
the open interval but this is
differentiable really for all x and so
let's show let's show that we can find
find
a c
that's inside the open interval that's a
member of the open interval that's in
the open interval
such that
such
that the derivative
at c
is equal to the average rate of change
over this interval or is equal to the
slope of the secant line between the two
end points of the interval so it's equal
to f of five
minus f of two
over
five
minus two and so i encourage you to
point to pause the video now and try to
find ac
where this is actually true
well to do that let's just calculate
what this has to be then let's just take
the derivative and set them equal and we
should be able to solve for our c
so let's see f of 5 minus f of 2 f of 5
is let's see let me f of 5
is equal to 25
minus 30
plus 8. so that's negative 5 plus 8 is
equal to three
f of two
is equal to two squared minus twelve so
it's four minus twelve plus eight that's
going to be zero so this is equal to
three over three which is equal to one f
prime of c is equal to needs to be equal
to one and so what is the derivative of
this
well let's see f prime
of x is equal to two x
minus
and so that's going to be neat we need
to figure out at what x value especially
it has to be within this in this open
interval at what x value is it equal to
1 so this needs to be equal to 1.
so let's add 6 to both sides you get 2x
is equal to 7 x is equal to 7 and a
halves 7 halves which is the same thing
as 3 and a half so it's definitely in
this interval right over here so we've
just found our c
c
is equal to 7 halves and let's just
graph this to really make sure that this
makes sense
so
let's let's this right over here is our
y-axis
and then this right over here is our
x-axis looks like all the action is
happening in the first and fourth
quadrants
so that is our
x-axis
and let's see let's say this is one
two
three
four and 5.
so we already know that 2 is one of the
zeros here so we know that our function
if we wanted to graph it
it intersects the x-axis right over here
and you can factor this out as x minus 2
times x minus four so our other the
other place where our function hits zero
is when x is equal to four right over
here our vertex is going to be right in
between at x is equal to three when x is
equal to three let's see nine minus
nine minus eighteen is negative 9 plus 8
so negative 1 so you have the point 3
negative 1 on it
and
so that's enough for us to
to graph and we also know at 5 we're at
3 so 1
3. so at 5 we are right over here
so over the interval that we care about
our graph looks something like this
so that's the
interval that we care about and we're
saying that we were looking for a c
whose slope is the same as the slope of
the secant line same as the slope of
the line between these two points and if
i were to just visually look at it i'd
say well yeah it looks like right around
there just based on my drawing the slope
of the tangent line looks like it's
parallel it looks like it has the same
slope looks like the tangent line is
parallel to the secant line and that
looks like it's right at
three and a half or seven halves so it
makes sense so this right over here is
our c c is equal to seven halves